MARK: Rafaela, I know
you feel grateful.
Yes.
To The Wonderful
Company, and they have done
things that no farmer will do.
Yes.
There's a park now.
There's--
- Yes, I know.
- The roads are better.
There's some houses.
But the wages are still minimum.
And the water is
still a problem.
Mm-hmm.
MAN: Arsenic.
Yeah, arsenic.
Si.
So the farm workers
don't have water to drink,
but the trees have
plenty of water to drink.
Yeah.
ROSANNA: Almost all the
water in this valley
is full of toxicity.
One of the first things
that happened to me when
I started working here is--
I was going door to
door, visiting residents,
and a couple of women
said, "Come in, come in."
And they offered me a
glass of what they were
calling, "Lost Hills Lemonade."
And they were laughing about it.
And I could smell it.
I could smell the chlorine.
And that was our introduction
to the water here.
Have you asked the
water district here
why it's coming out yellow?
I have, and their
response that I've received
is, "Well, it's an
infrastructure problem."
because--
That means it's the
pipes in the house?
It's the pipes in the house.
But with all this
infrastructure changes,
did the Resnicks improve
the water system?
No.
The infrastructure of the pipes
going into people's homes?
No.
And this is what we're seeing
throughout Kern County.
That some areas are
parched, and some farms
are drying up, because who
holds the rights to that water?
And who is going to
benefit most from being
able to grow more pistachios
and more pomegranates?
That's the California story.
There has always been
a fight over the water.
And just like any war, it's
just collateral damage.
Yeah.